الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
اما يجلس
تركيا الصحه العالميه تحذر من الوضع الطبي
المتدهور شمال سوريا والمعابر مع تركيا
تفتح لاستقبال الاموات والمنكوبين
ومع نهايه اليوم العاشر بعد الزلزال تركيا
تبدا انتشار جثه الضحايا بلباس خاص لمنع
انتشار الاوبئه
تحقيق استقصائي لصحفي امريكي يؤكد ان
واشنطن وراء التفجير نوت ستريم وموسكو
تطلب عقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
مباحثات غير مباشره بين امريكا وايران
لتبادل السجناء والافراج عن مليارات
الدولارات من الاموال الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه ايضا نبدا من
الخبر الذي ورد قبل قليل وقبل الدخول في
اخبار تداعيات الزلزال بعد عشره ايام على
وقوعنا توقف مع الخبر الذي ورد قبل قليل
عن العطل الذي ابلغ عنه مستخدمون على منصه
تويتر في الشرق الاوسط وابلغوا عن عطله
اذن في تطبيق وموقع تويتر منذ نصف ساعه
قبل ان يعود للعبد
[موسيقى]
اذا معنا من الرياض عبد الله السبع الباحث
في الشؤون التقنيه عبد الله اهلا بك معنا
ما الذي حصل لتويتر قبل قليل
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه على هذه المداخله
تويتر قبل شوي حصل في عطل تقريبا لمده ما
يقرب النصف ساعه طبعا تويتر توقف بشكل
كامل عن عند المستخدمين متوقع ان العطل هو
عطل للاسف دوري طبعا خلال السنوات الماضيه
كان تويتر يتميز بميزه جدا مهمه هو عدم
توقف المنصه زي ما تذكرون بدايه السنه
الحاليه تقريبا كانت عمليه الاستحواذ على
المنصه ومن بعدها بدات عمليه
التعريف تعطل خلال شهرين نعم هل هذه
الاعطال في تويتر لها علاقه بتخفيض اعداد
الموظفين بعد استحواذ ايلون ماسك على
اداره الشركه
للان للان المنصه ما قاعد تصرح عن الاسباب
لكن يتوقع ان بسبب قله المهندسين اللي
موجودين في المنصه قد يكون هذا احد
الاسباب وقد يكون هناك سبب اخر وهو موضوع
الانتقام من الاقالات اللي حصلت في تويتر
وهذا امر وارد وغير مستبعد لكن ارجح موضوع
قله عدد الموظفين المسؤولين عن المنصه في
الفتره الحاليه عبد الله العطله كان فقط
في دول الشرق الاوسط امطار دول اخرى
حتى الان ما في توضيح عن هذا الموضوع لكن
متوقع انه يكون في جميع انحاء العالم وليس
فقط في الشرق الاوسط تقريبا توقف لمده نصف
ساعه تقريبا
توه رجع فما نقدر نعرف تفاصيل كثيره عن
حجم العطل او مشاكل لكن التوقعات تشير من
العطل الموجود في كل انحاء العالم طيب عبد
الله في هكذا اعطال هل علينا ان نقلق على
خصوصيتنا على تويتر
ما اتوقع ان الموضوع
يستحق القلق لان تعطل البرامج او تعطل
المنصات هو امر اعتيادي سناب شات كانت
تتعطل كل سنه تقريبا من عشره الى 15 مره
الفيسبوك تعطل مرتين الواتساب تعطل اكثر
من مره الاعطال الامر وارد جدا في
المنصات التقنيه بسبب المشاكل اللي هم
يمرون فيها لذلك الموضوع جدا اعتيادي
وبسيط وله موضوع يستحق الخوف على بي
خصوصياتنا اللي موجوده داخل المنصه هو قد
يكون خلل في السيرفرات خلل في الاتصال ما
يوصل الى موضوع هجوم سيبراني حتى الان ما
في توضيحات كبيره عن هذا الموضوع لكن ممكن
خلال نصف ساعه القادمه او ساعه يكون في
توضيحات كبيره خاصه لو كان هجوم شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه الاضاحات عبد الله
السبع الباحث في الشؤون التقنيه من الرياض
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات من التشرد والالم واللجوء عاد
السوريون الى بلدهم عبر معابر حدوديه مع
تركيا عوده مليئه برائحه الموت عاد سوريون
امواتا ليدفنوا في قراهم التي خرجوا منها
بحثا عن امان خارج دائره الحرب السوريه
ومن نجا من الموت جراء الزلزال عدما كوبا
الى بلده ايضا ماساه تضاف الى ماسي شعب
حتى المساعدات فيه بحاجه الى موافقات
واجراءات وحتى تفاهمات مساعدات ما بعد
زلزال لم يعترف بالجغرافيا فضرب تركيا
وسوريا وبينما فتحت ابوابها قبل يومين
امام المنكوبين كارثه من السوريين لم
تتوقف عنها شاحنات نقل الجثمين وترتبط
محافظات ادلب مشاهدينا بالاراضي التركيه
بمعبر باب الهوى الحدودي والى الشرق قليلا
هناك معبر باب السلامه ومعبر الراعي وصولا
الى اقصى الشمال الشرقي اذ ترتبط الاراضي
السوريه بتركيا من خلال معبري تل ابيض
وراس العين
[موسيقى]
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس
من الرئيس السوري بشر الاسد فتح المعابر
الحدوديه مع تركيا الصحه العالميه اشارت
الى ان المنطقه التي تثير اعلى مستويات
القلق حاليا هي شمال غرب سوريا مؤكدا ان
النظام الصحي هش بصوره هائله والناس
يعيشون جحيما
[موسيقى]
الاف الناجين لا زالوا ينتظرون تدفق
المزيد من المساعدات الانسانيه والتي تبقى
الحاجه ماسه اليها في المناطق المتضرره
دخول المساعدات امتدا ليشمل معبر باب
السلامه الحدودي والذي شهد دخول اول قافله
مساعدات امميه عبر هذا المعبر الذي يفصل
تركيا ومناطق سيطره الفصائل المعارضه في
شمال سوريا وتتالف قافله المساعدات هذه من
11 شاحنه مقدمه من المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
التي افادت ان المساعدات تشمل مستلزمات
ايواء وبطانيات وسجاده اما فيما يتعلق
بمعبر باب الهوى فان دخول شاحنات
المساعدات متواصل نقلا عن مصادر العربيه
حيث بلغ اجمالي الشاحنات التي عبرت حتى
الان 106 شاحنات
[موسيقى]
قافلات المساعده من شانها ان تخفف من حده
وضع الناجين في المناطق المتضرره في سوريا
رغم ان المتطلبات تبدو كبيره للغايه وكان
الامين العام للامم المتحده قد اطلق نداء
طارئا لجمع نحو 400 مليون دولار لمساعده
ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا على مدى ثلاثه
اشهر مشيرا الى ان المنظمه تعمل ايضا على
اطلاق نداء مماثل لمساعده تركيا وقدمت
الامم المتحده 50 مليون دولار من
المساعدات فورا بعد وقوع الزلزال من صندوق
المسؤوليات العاجله ولكن الاحتياجات اكثر
من ذلك يقول امينها العام
وخلقت قضيه فتح المعابر في سوريا جدلا
واسعا حيث ظلت مغلقه في الايام القليله
الاولى التي عقلت الزلزال لاعتبارات
سياسيه قبل ان تجد
المشطله طريقها للحل لاعتبارات انسانيه او
المشكله عفوا طريقها للحل وكان النظام
السوري قد وافق على فتح ثلاثه معابر
حدوديه بين تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا لمده
ثلاثه اشهر وجاءت موافقه النظام من اجل
ادخال مساعدات انسانيه للمتضررين من
الزلزال حيث سمح النظام بنقل المساعدات
ايضا الى مناطق المعارضه هذا ولا يتم دخول
اي قوافل مساعدات من الاراضي الخاضعه
لسيطره النظام الى هذه المنطقه من دون
موافقه دمشق
معنى من معبر باب الهوى صحفيه محمد الاشقر
محمد اهلا بك معنا انقل لنا الصوره من حيث
انت من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي بين تركيا
وسوريا
نعم يعني في الحقيقه تستمر يستمر دخول
الوافدين من تركيا الى سوريا وفق قرار
الاجازه الذي يسمح بدخول السوريين حاملي
بطاقه الحمايه المؤقته
الصادره عن الولايات التي اصابها الضرر
والتي تدمرت في
تركيا يعني لحد هذه اللحظه اخر رقم اخذناه
من اداره معبر باب الهوى هو 1500 شخص
دخلوا الى هذا المعبر وبعد ان اخذنا هذه
الاحصائيه تم رصدنا دخول خمسه حافلات تقل
المزيد من الاشخاص
السوريين طبعا هناك العديد من التسهيلات
والاجراءات التي تنفذ من قبل الطرفين
الطرف التركي والطرف السوري هنا في سوريا
يعني كما تشاهدون خلفي على تجري الاجراءات
في مكتب الهجره والجوازات ليتم بعدها نقل
هؤلاء المسافرين عبر باصات المعبر الى
محيط مدينه سرمدا ومن هناك يتم استقبال
الوافدين من قبل الاهاليهم ومن ليس لديه
ماوى يعني تعمل يعمل اشخاص من مختلف الفرق
والمنظمات ووزاره التنميه هنا على تامين
ماوى لهم ولو كان مؤقتا نعم طيب محمد يعني
هناك يعني مع مع تولى الايام بعد الزلزال
برزت هذه يعني الرغبه لدى السوريين الذين
هربوا من سوريا ولجوا الى تركيا طوال
السنوات الماضيه بعد الزلزال هناك من قرر
ان يدفن اقربائه الذين قتلوا في الزلزال
الاوتوفوا في الزلزال داخل بلده في
الاراضي السوريه وهناك من قرر العوده ما
الذي يعني ما الذي نقله اليك من تحدثت
اليهم هناك في المعبر
نعم يعني في الحقيقه يعني اغلب من تحدثنا
اليهم هنا وصفوا لنا المشهد في تركيا بانه
المروع جدا يعني نتيجه الحادثه وهذه وهذا
وهذه الكارثه التي ضربت عده ولايات في
تركيا طبعا اغلب الوافدين الى حد هذه
اللحظه هم من حاملي بطاقه الحمايه المؤقته
في مدينه
انطاكيا احدى الاكبر الولايات التي تضررت
في جنوب تركيا طبعا ان سمحت
لمعلومات اكثر ان استضيف معي السيد مازن
علوش مدير مكتب العلاقات العامه والتنسيق
الاعلامي في معبر باب الهوى استاذ مازن
مرحبا بك بالبدايه ما هي الاجراءات وما هي
التسهيلات للسوريين الذين يودون العوده
الى سوريا طبعا بعد عدد جلسات بيننا وبين
الاخوه في الجانب التركي تم التوصل لاقرار
لاهلنا السوريين اللاجئين في تركيا
والمقيمين في الولايات التي تم الاعلان
انها منكوبه بان ياتوا الى بلدهم سوريا في
زياره حريث ما تهدا الاحوال هناك وتنتهي
حاله الطوارئ طبعا بفضل الله تم اقرار هذه
الاجازه قبل يومين لشاهدنا اليوم صباح
اليوم توهد اهلنا ضمن هذه الاجازه منذ
ساعات الصباح الباكر وحتى الان نحن في
منتصف الليل يستمر التوافق اهلنا في اجازه
الخاصه استثنائيه
للسوريين مقيمين في الولايات المنكوبه بلغ
عدد الواصلين حتى تاريخ الساعه قرابه 1750
مواطن ربما سينتهي الدخول بعد قليل بحسب
ما بلغنا الان جانب تركي انه لم تبقى
مسافرين على ان يعاد في الصباح الباكر
الساعه الثامنه صباحا استئناف دخولهم
سيستمر الدخول بشكل يومي لا نعلم متى الحد
النهائي اليوم النهائي لايقاف الدخول
الامر تجربه بفضل الله باعلى احسن ما يرام
نحن كنا نقوم باستقبالهم منذ لحظه وص من
البوابه التركيه ننقلهم بحافلات المعبر
الى هنا الى صاله الهجره والجوازات هنا كل
مواطن يقوم بختم اوراقه واخذ الدوري
العوده لتركيا بعد انتهاء الاجازه ومن ثم
نقوم بنقله مباشره الى ساحه مدينه سرمدا
هنالك ايضا الاهالي يقومون بانتظارهم ومن
ليس لديها هذه ايضا خصصنا حافلات لنقلهم
الى اي مدينه يريدونها بالنسبه للسوريين
الذين ليس لديهم احد هنا يقيمون عنده ايضا
الاخوه في وزاره التنميه وضعوا نقطه هنا
في في صاله الهجره
لديهم فريق موجود هنا يقومون بتسجيل اهالي
وايضا نقله مباشره الى مساكن مخصصه لاهلنا
المتضررين من زلزال القادمين من تركيا بان
كي لا يبقى في العراء في في منطقتنا الحمد
لله الامور جيده بفضل الله تعالى
استاذ مازن تحدثنا عن عوده السوريين
المنكوبين ولكن ماذا عن عوده الجنازات
السوريين ما هي ما هو العدد الذي وثقتموه
حتى هذه اللحظه وما هي الاجراءات لدخول
جسامين السوريين القتلى نتيجه هذا الزلزال
طبعا
منذ اول ايام الزلزال في مساء يوم الاثنين
بدات تردنا تباعا جثامين لاهلنا السوريين
الذين قضوا في الزلزال في تركيا
وصلنا على مدار الايام الماضيه وحتى
التاريخ اليوم
جثامين ل 1500 شهيد وصلونا من
معظمها من العائلات عائلات كامله توفيت في
في الزلزال
طريقه نقلهم الى الى المناطقنا طبعا كل
شهيد لديه اقرباء هنا وايضا له يديه معارف
في الطرف التركي يقومون بنقل جنازته الى
مقبره مدينه الريحانيه هنالك قوموا بتسجيل
اسمه
ثم تقوم سياره الصحه التركيه بنقله الى
بوابتنا من الطرف التركي لدينا نحن هنا
قسم الجنازات التابع لمكتب تنسيق الطبي في
المعبر فريق متكامل موجود على مدار 24
ساعه يقوم باستقبال الجثيمين ومن ثم
يقومون بتوثيق الاسماء
ومن ثم نقلها بسياره الجنازات الى البوابه
من الطرف الاخر هنالك يكون اهالي المتوفى
ينتظرون يقوم بنقل جسمانه الى مدنهم
وبلداتهم الى دفنها هناك اريد ان انوه ان
هذا الرقم هو ليس كل السوريين الذين توفوا
في الزلزال فلدينا مئات السوريين الذين هم
اصولهم تعود الى المدن التي تحت سيطره
النظام هؤلاء كلهم تم دفنهم في تركيا
بالاضافه الى انه ما زالت مئات او الاف
السوريين ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ ربما ستجرد
تصلنا جثامنهم تباعا خلال الايام القادمه
هذا بما يخص موضوع الجثمان الشهداء سؤال
اخير استاذ مازن يعني
هناك يدور حديث حول افتتاح معبر اخر
لاستقبال السوريين الراغبين بالعوده الى
سوريا ما هي المعلومات التي تملكها ما هي
المعابر التي سيتم افتتاحها ومتى سيبدا
العوده
سيتمكن السوريون من العوده من خلال هذه
المعهد طبعا الاجازه تم قرارها من عده
معبر
بداوا بمعبر الابيض قبل يومين في منطقه
الذي
يكون على منطقه نبع السلام شمال مدينه
الرقه ومدينه الحسكه
من ثم اليوم بدات عندنا ربما ستبدا غدا او
بعد غد في معبر باب السلامه الذي يصل
الريف حلب منطقه درع الفرات في في ولايه
كلس ايضا معبر الحمام الذي يصل بين عفرين
اقليم هاتاي ايضا اليوم بدات الدخول منه
يعني هنالك اربعه اربعه معابر ربما ستفتح
ايضا خلال الايام القادمه الدخول ايضا من
معبر جرابلس ومعبر الراعي ان شاء الله
بحسب ما وصلنا اما حتى تاريخ اللحظه معبر
باب الهوى ومعبر الابيض ومعبر الحمام طبعا
العدد الاكبر هو معبر باب الهوى وصلنا
اليوم 1750 مواطن بالمقابل وصل من تعب
الابيض اليوم 850 مواطن شكرا لالك سيدًا
على هذا الوقت طبعا كما نعم نعم اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا الحقيقه على هذه الصوره الحيه
ايضا على معبر من معبر باب الهوى وشكر
موصول لضيفك ايضا شكرا لك محمد
نشر الدفاع المدني مقطعا اثناء انقاذي
طفله وامراه من تحت الانقاض في مدينه ادلب
خلال اليوم الاول من الزلزال نشاهد اولا
يا رب
يلا قولي يا رب وصلت قريب عليك خمس دقايق
قولي يا رب
[موسيقى]
شباب اعطونا حرام نغطيه
عندك نتابع من شمال ادلب مع الصحفيه مسلم
السيد عيسى مسلم اهلا بك معنا كيف هو
الوضع الانساني والمعيشي لسكان ريف ادلب
بعد عشره ايام من الزلزال
يعني
ينتظرون ان تقدم المساعدات الاساسيه التي
تغطي احتياجاتهم العاجله والطارئه اذا
يعني تحدثنا عن قسمين لهذه الازمه قسم
الطوارئ والعاجل وهو الذي تحتاج فيه
الاهالي السلم الغذائيه الاطعام والخيام
او المراكز الايواء وغيرها حتى اللحظه لم
يتم تامين سوى 15% من هذه الاحتياجات وهي
الطارئه والعاجله ومن المتوقع ان تزداد
هذه الاحتياجات خصوصا مع موجات الصقيع
الحاليه اتحدث عن 200 شاحنه وصلت الى هذه
المناطق المتضرره 75 منها من مناطق الداخل
السوري قدمتها الاهالي
يعني اللجان الخيريه في منطقه دير الزور
ووصلت الى مناطق جنديرس والريف حلب
الشمالي وتقريبا 125 شاحنه وصلت عبر
الحدود كل هذه الشاحنات لا توثق او لا
تخدم حتى اللحظه الى حتى 15% من الحاله
الانسانيه وتسد هذه الاحتياجات الواضحه
على ارض الواقع ان دائره الاحتياجات تتوسع
حقيقه بشكل كبير جدا
تعاني المنطقه من موجات صقيع وبرد حاليا
وايضا بنفس الوقت هناك الاف العوائل لا
تزال تفترش الطرقات والمراكز الهواء
وغيرها وهي بحاجه الى ايواء حقيقي الى
حلول مستدامه لا الى حلول يعني عاجله فقط
وغيرها الاهالي هنا تطالب بشكل اساسي بان
يتم البدء باعاده اعمار منازلهم باعاده
افتتاح القرى السكنيه نتحدث هنا عن 35 الف
عائله ليس لديها اليوم ايه منزل او مركز
تؤوا اليه وبالتالي لا تريد ان نفتتح
مخيمات جديده يعني في المنطقه هنا نتحدث
عن الف ولكن يعني كان هناك يعني شهاده من
مدير المجلس المحلي لمدينه حارم في ريف
ادلب بان يعني هذا الزلزال اعاد حارم يعني
الى نقطه الصفر يعني انه حجم الاضرار كبير
فيها جدا
حدثني عن الوضعيه كذلك فيما يتعلق ذكرت ان
المساعدات التي دخلت حتى الان تكفي فقط
لخمسه عشر بالمئه من حاجيات السكان نتحدث
عن الحاجيات لكي يعيشوا الان ماذا عن رفع
الانقاض كما ذكرت انه امكانيه اعاده اعمار
هذه البيوت هل هناك يعني مساعدات في هذا
الاطار كذلك دخلت
يعني لا لا تسجيل او لا حتى اللحظه لا
توثيق لاي دخول لمساعدات مخصصه للانقاذ
والكوارث ويبدو ان فرق الدفاع المدني
هتتعامل مع الموضوع على انه لن تصل ايه
مساعدات وقالت ان يعني هذه المساعدات لم
يتم اعطاء اي وعود مخصصه لهذه المساعدات
المخصصه للكوارث وبالتالي فرق الدفاع
المدني تعمل بنفس بطيء بالامكانيات
المتاحه لاستخراج فقط من تبقى من جثث
القتلى لكن بالمقابل حتى الان لا تزال
العوائل تبلغ عن مفقودين يعني العوائل كان
لديها الامل مثلا في الدرجه الاولى ان
يخرج ابنائها احياء لكن لم يخرجوا
وبالتالي كان لديهم امل ان يجدوهم في
المستشفيات ربما او غيرها ولم يجدوهم
وبالتالي انقطع الامل بتواجد ابنائهم يعني
لا وجود لابنائهم الا تحت انقاذ المباني
التي سويت بالارض هذه المراحل قد تستغرق
على الاقل عشره ايام هنا في المنطقه حتى
يتم استخراج كل من هم مفقودين حتى في تحت
الانقاذ هذه المباني وبالتالي الارقام
ايضا للمفقودين
وضحايا هذا الزلزال متوقع ان تزيد بشكل
كبير خلال الايام القليله القادمه في نفس
في نفس السياق ايضا فرق الدفاع المدني
قالت انها الان تعمل بشكل روتيني بطيء
بحسب الامكانيات المتوفره بين يديها شكرا
جزيلا لك مسلم السيد عيسى كنت معنا من
شمال ادلب
هذا ولا تزالوا بلده جنديرس في عفرين شمال
غرب سوريا تعاني من اثار الزلزال المدمر
الذي حل بها قبل عشره ايام ان جون من
اهالي البلده يحاولون ادراك حجم الكارثه
التي حلت بهم مطالبين باغاثتهم وتقديمهم
المساعدات العاجله لهم
فوق تلال من الركام ينتظر وحيدا واستحاله
من الصدمه والالم انه من جنديرس البلده
المنكوبه اثر الزلزال المدمر
الدمار في كل مكان وناجون يتجرعون الام
فقدان عائلاتهم واقاربهم يحاولون استيعاب
حجم الخسائر الكبيره التي حلت بهم نحن
نبرك تحت هيك ما في اي مشكله بس اطفال
نساء
المصاب اللي طالعناه من تحت التراب يعني
ردود كذا هلق نزلت انا اولادي على المشفى
جسمه كله ازرق
على الارض تماما اكثر من الف بناء خارج
كان يعني لا يصلح للسكن انا 3,900 عائله
لا تملك اي ماوى
في حقول بالقرب من المباني المدمره نصبت
بعض الخيام لايواء المنكوبين وقسم اخر
افترش ارضيه صاله رياضيه بانتظار اي
مساعدات قد تخفف من معاناتهم
عندي انا شهيد الحمد لله
وضعنا كتير تعبان
جنديرس هي المنطقه الاكثر كارثيه وتضررا
من الزلزال وفق التقارير وهو ما تعكسه
شكاوى ونداءات سكانها الذين يطالبون
بمساعدات عاجله تساعدهم على الصمود امام
الكارثه التي حلت بهم
وين المساعدات ملوك الشيخ العربيه
معنى من دمشق الكتب والمحلل السياسي غسان
يوسف غسان اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه
اليوم شهدنا اتفاقا بين الحكومه السوريه
والاداره الذاتيه الكرديه لفتح معبر
التايهه لادخال المساعدات وهناك اتفاق على
فتح معبرين مع تركيا هل هناك
معابر اخرى ستفتح امام هذه الازمه
الانسانيه
تحياتي لك ولساده المشاهدين يعني تعرف بان
يعني اليوم الاول كان هناك توجه الى
الرئيس الاسد يعني
عقده بعد وقوع زلزال مباشره وكان التوجيه
للحكومه بايصال المساعدات
الى كل الاراضي الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه
وايضا يعني الحكومه اكدت ذلك وايضا اللقاء
الذي جمع الرئيس بكل من مدير منظمه الصحه
العالميه وايضا الوكيل الشؤون الانسانيه
للامم المتحده
ايضا تم التاكيد على ذلك اليوم يعني في
بعد هذا طبعا يعني سيكون هنا يعني زياده
عدد المعابر التي هي يعني موجوده بين
المناطق يعني مثلا لديك
الم يتاخر القرار قليلا او التحرك قليلا
لانه من اليوم الاول للزلزال يعني هناك
مناطق في شمال غرب سوريا تركت وحيده
لمواجهه اثار الزلزال المدمر لماذا تعار
الحكومه السوريه في دمشق فتح المعابر
يعني انت تعرف منذ بدايه يعني هذا كان
هناك توجه من الحكومه وايضا يعني تم يعني
ارسال قافله محمله
وتوقفت على معبر سراقي ولكن كانت الجهاد
الموجوده في ادلب وفي المناطق الاخرى وعرق
الوصول هذا الشيء يعني كانت الدوله
السوريه تقول ذلك ولم يكن احد يصدق وجاءت
لممتحده واكدت عبر مكتبه في دمشق لان هيئه
تحرير الشام تؤكد ذلك لا لا اقول لك اكثر
من ذلك لان هيئه يعني قامت بالضغط على
المواطنين للتظاهر والقول لا نريد دخول
المساعدات يعني هذا الموضوع من المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الدوله السوريه واعتقد
يعني لان هذا فيه ظلم واسحاق المواطنين
الذين يعني سمعت التقرير الذي تكلم به
يعني مراسلكم وايضا عن المواطنين بان
قانون وليس هناك مساعدات مساعدات وايضا
اكثر من ذلك هناك اقتتال ما بين المجموعات
على تلك المناطق ويمكرون الحواجزون على
المساعدات ولذلك يعني كان الراعي التركي
او لنقول كانت تركي يعني تسيطر على هذه
المنطقه وهي يعني من ضبط هذه المنطقه ولكن
تعرف يعني في تركيا هناك زلزال ونحن
قلوبنا مع اخوتنا ولذلك حدثت هذه الفوضى
ولكن اليس من واجب الدوله ان تقوم بما
عليها المساعدات الى كل مكان انا اقول لك
هذا واجب الدوله وايضا فتح المحابس لتعرف
بان الرئيس قد وافق على فتح المحابر لمده
ثلاثه اشهر واحد
يعني مثل المعبر الراعي ومعبر باب السلامه
واليوم يعني تكلمت حضرتك عن معبر التاريخ
وربما يكون هناك معابر اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك
غسان يوسف انتم والمحلل السياسي كنتم معنا
من دمشق ومشاهدينا لدينا حصيله جديده
لضحايا الزلزال كما تشاهدون على العاجل
اسفل شاشتنا نقلا على المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان الحصيله ترتفع في سوريا الى 5000
650 قتيلا في سوريا مازلنا نتحدث يعني في
حدود اكثر من 41 الف قتيل في البلدين في
تركيا وسوريا جراء الزلزال بعد
عشره ايام طبعا
وهناك عدد يعني كبير جدا من الضحايا جثث
الضحايا ما تزال تحت الانقاض الامر الذي
بدات فيه السلطات التركيه اليوم في بعض
المناطق فهذه الحصيله اذا المرشحه
للارتفاع اكثر والمرصد السوري يقول اذا
يؤكد هذا مئات الجثث لا زالت عالقه تحت
الانقاض ولم تصل الفرق الانقاذ اليها
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه مع نهايه اليوم
العاشر تركيا تبدا انتشال جثث الضحايا
بلباس خاص لمنع انتشار الاوبئه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عشره ايام مرت اذن على
وقوع الزلزال جروح الالم لم تندم بعد لكن
الامر الواقع بات يقتضي الان تجاوز الصدمه
والتحضير لمرحله ما بعد الكارثه في تركيا
بدا الحديث عن خطط اعاده الاعمار ومواعيد
البدء فيها وذلك في الولايات العشر
المتضرره فعمليات رفع الانقاض وازاله اثار
الزلزال بدات في بعض البلدات بينما تتواصل
عمليات الانقاذ في اخرى كما ردد ذلك مرارا
رئيس تركيا
فان اعمال اعاده الاعمار في المناطق
المنكوبه ستنطلق خلال ايام التاكيد جاء
على لسان وزير البيئه والتخطيط العمراني
التركي مراد كروم الذي اعلن ان اعمال
اعاده الاعمار في المناطق المنكوبه جراء
الزلزلين ستبدا نهايه الشهر الحالي ولحد
الان فان حصيله الدمار تب نقلا عن الوزير
التركي دائما فانه تم تحديد واحد واربعين
الفا وسبعمائه مبنى متضرر من الزلزلين في
الولايات العشر علما ان عمليه تقييم
الاضرار لم تنتهي بعد بشكل كلي
وعمليه ازاله الانقاض ستعقبها مباشره
عمليات اعمار واسعه اذا النبي هدف تعويض
ناجينا والمتضررين على ممتلكاتهم التي
تضررت فحسب افاده الصحيفه افاده صحفيه
عفوا للرئيس التركي فان الحكومه ستبدا
مطلع مرسى المقبل بناء 30 الف وحده سكنيه
للمتضررين من الزلزال ورغم مرور عشره ايام
على وقوع الزلزال الا ان الامال تبقى
قائمه في العثور على ناجين لكنها ضئيله
فضائل الفرص لم يوقف عمليات الانقاذ في
بعض البلدات وهو ما اكد عليه وزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان سويلم الذي شدد
على ان فرق الانقاذ لن تتوقفا حتى العثور
على اخر ناجح
واحضيت تركيا بتضامن دولي واسع حيث تلقت
الكثير من المساعدات والاعانات من دول
مختلفه وتواصل طائرات عسكريه تركيه شحن
المساعدات الانسانيه التي ترسلها دول
مختلفه الى مطار اتاتورك في اسطنبول وهذا
الى المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال وبهذا
الخصوص اشار وزير الخارجيه التركيه
عقب الزل
زال فان
سته مثلا ارسلت فرقه انقاذ الى المناطق
المتضرره في تركيا وان 34 سفاره تقدم
الدعم والمساعده في مناطق الزلزال كما
شارك في عمليات الانقاذ العديد من
المتطوعين من حول العالم بلغ عددهم عشره
الاف متطوع اجنبي ساهموا في رفع الانقاض
ومع نهايه اليوم العاشر من الزلزال المدمر
في تركيا بدات تختفي عمليات البحث وعمليات
رفع الانقاض حيث عدد كبير من الموتى
والمفقودين واصبحت فرق الانقاذ ترتدي
ملابس العزل خشيه انتشار الامراض والاوبئه
نتابع التفاصيل مع تقرير موفدنا الى هاتاي
عمار الهندي
بدات تختفي عمليات البحث عن الناجين تحت
الانقاض العمليات هنا تتركز على انتشال
الجثث الموتى والمفقودين وفرق الانقاذ
بدات تاخذ شكلا ولونا جديدا ترتدي ملابس
العزل خشيه الامراض والاوبئه وانتشارها
خصوصا مع وجود اعداد كبيره من الجثامين
التي لا تزال تحت انقاض البنايات المدمره
في انطاكيا فيها تاي واسر تبحث عما لديها
من المفقودين والذين لم يعرف مصيرهم حتى
اللحظه عمار الهندي انطاكيا
وخطوره الزلزال المشاهدين لا تتوقفوا مع
نهايته بل تستمر عبر الهزات الارتداديه
التي تكون قوتها اضعف نسبيا من الهزه
الرئيسيه وقد تكون موجه الهزات الارتداديه
لم تنتهي بعد في تركيا حيث اشار التوقعات
الى امكانيه حدوث هزه ارتداديه قويه في
الايام القادمه صاحب التنبؤ ليس الا
العالم الهولندي فرانك هوجربيتس الذي توقع
حدوث زلزال التركي السوري قبل ثلاثه ايام
من وقوعه هذا العالم الهولندي اشار الى
امكانيه حدوث هزه ارتداديه ربما قد تصل
شدتها الى السته درجات وقد تحدث بوسط
تركيا او حولها في الايام المقبله ونشر
العالم الهولندي هذا التوقع على حسابه على
تويتر لهيئه المسح الهندسي للنظام الشمسي
في هولندا الذي يشغل فيه منصب الرئيس
التنفيذي غير ان هذه التوقعات يقول
منتقلوها بانها ليست دقيقه
ارسلت اكثر من دوله عربيه وغربيه واوروبيه
كلاب الانقاذ الى تركيا وسوريا للعثور على
العالقين تحت الانقاض بعد الزلزال المدمر
حيث اصبحت الكلاب عضوا اساسيا في فرق
الانقاذ لمورون لمرونه تنقلها بين الحجاره
ولتفريقها بين الاموات والاحياء لكن لم
تصل الكلاب لهذه الدرجه الا بعد تدريب
صارخ
وسوريا بحثا عن المفقودين اصبح وجوده جزءا
لا يتجزا في عمليه العثور على المحاصرين
بين الانقاض كائنات تجازف كما الانسان
بحياتها من اجل الاخرين لكن تدريب الكلاب
امر لازم لتهيئتها في مثل هذه الكوارث
فكيف توظف هيئه الاغاثه هذا الحيوان
المفضل عالميا في جهود المساعده نبدا من
ولادته حيث تساهم امه في تحفيز الخلايا
العصبيه عبر لمس الجرو الذي يدخل في
التنشئه الاجتماعيه
تليها مرحله يتدخل فيها البشر ينتقون
الكلاب وهي في عمر لا يتجاوز ثمانيه
اسابيع لبدء تجهيزها للمهام الصعبه ثم
يعرضون هذه الجراء لاشخاص وحيوانات وبيئات
مختلفه مما يساعدها على الشعور بالراحه
والثقه في المواقف الجديده
فالتدريب الذي تخضع له كلاب الانقاذ صارم
وواسع النطاق وبما انها تمتلك حاسه شم
قويه يحاول المدربون ان ينموا هذه المهاره
الى ان تستطيع الكلاب تمييز رائحه البشر
الحي منهم والميت وفي حالات الزلازل يتم
تمرينهم على البحث في الحطام وتسلق
السلالم والتنقل في المساحات الضيقه
وحينما تشك الكلاب بوجود انسان حي في تلال
الدمار تلك قد تنبح او تنبش الارض لتنبيه
الفريق بان احدهم هنا واذا استدعى الامر
يجلبون كلبا اخر لتاكيد الموقع ثم تسخير
اليات عملهم على مكان بعيده بروتو في
زلزال تركيا وفريده في المكسيك مثالان على
ابطال حقيقيين ليسوا شجعانا في الكوارث
فحسب بل ان الكلاب تسترق السمع وتستشعر
انفاسا تحت حجاره جافيه على اجساد الاطفال
اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه عوده الحركه الى
طبيعتها في مطري فرانكفورت وميونخ بعد عطل
معلوماتي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت البعثه الروسيه في
الامم المتحده انها ستدعو الى اجتماعي
لمجلس الامن يوم 22 من فبراير لمناقشه
تفجير خط الغاز نولد ستريم تحت بحر
البلطيق وقالت البعثه الروسيه ان مجلس
الامن تتم دعوته لمناقشه تخريب الخط ياتي
ذلك بعد تحقيق استقصائي لصحفي الامريكي
اكد خلاله ان الولايات المتحده وضعت
متفجرات على الخط اثناء مناورات في بحر
البلطيق ثم فجرتها لاحقا فيما وصف البيت
الابيض هذا التحقيق بانه من وحي الخيال
[موسيقى]
على بعد ايام من اتمام الحرب في اوكرانيا
لعامها الاول تتواصل المعارك على العديد
من الجبهات تقلبات عديده طرات على ارض
المعركه ابرزها تمكن القوات الروسيه من
دخول مدن كانت سحبت منها في وقت سابق من
بين هذه المدن مدينه ليمان التي عادت
روسيا للسيطره عليها وذلك نقلا عن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه هذا وتواصل القوات الروسيه
تقدمها في محور كوبيانسكو والذي يشهد حرب
شوارع دار بين الجنود الروس والقوات
الاوكرانيه تراجع اخر سجلته القوات
الاوكرانيه هذه المره في منطقه لوجانسك
حيث نجحت القوات الروسيه في اختراق خطين
في خطوط الدفاع الاوكرانيه على الجبهه
الشرقيه للتتراجع القوات الاوكرانيه
بثلاثه كيلومترات
[موسيقى]
نقلت شبكه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه عن
مصادر المطلعه ان اداره بايدن تجري
محادثات غير مباشره مع ايران بشان تبادل
المحتمل للاسرع اشارت المصادر الى ان تلك
المفاوضات احرز التقدما لكن ما زال من غير
الواضح فاذا كان سيتم التوصل للاتفاق
النهائي فيما بحث الدبلوماسيون الامريكيون
والايرانيون ترتيبات المحتمله لكيفيه
تحويل الاموال المجمده في كوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
اسلحه ايرانيه بايد اوكرانيه وبتدخل
امريكي الفكره تبدو غير عاديه لكنها ممكنه
حيث يفكر الجيش الامريكي فعلا في ارسال
الاف الاسلحه الايرانيه الى اوكرانيا وكان
الجيش الامريكي قد صادر هذه الاسلحه سابقا
عندما كانت متجهه الى
المقاتلين المدعومين في ايران او
المدعومين من ايران في اليمن صحيفه جورنال
كشفت عن الموضوع
ونقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انهم
يبحثون هذا الامر
وتشمل الاسلحه بندقيه هجوميه وذخائر فضلا
عن صواريخ مضاده للدبابات وادوات للتفجير
وكانت البحريه الامريكيه قد اعترضت سفنا
تحمل اسلحه ايرانيه قباله الساحل اليمني
في خليج عمان يعتقد انها كانت متجهه من
ايران لدعم جماعه الحسين في اليمن
[موسيقى]
عادت حركه النقل الجوي تدريجيا الى
طبيعتها في مطري فرانكفورت في غرب المانيا
وميونخ بعد اضطرابات بسبب عطل معلومتي
واثقره هذا العطل على رحلات مجموعه
لوفانزا الجويه وكانت لفتانزا الجويه
الالمانيه قد اعلنت الغاء الرحله لمختلف
الشركات المملوكه لها واظهرت لوحه الهبوط
في مطار فرانكفورت عددا كبيرا من الرحله
الملغات اثر هذا العطل وتحدثت وسائل
الاعلام الالمانيه عن مشاهد فوضى في
المطارات ومشكلات في انظمه تسجيل الركاب
وكتبت الشركه في تبريده لها ان مجموعه من
الخبراء يعملون على معرفه سبب العطل
وتحديد حجمه
هسه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
الصحه العالميه تحذر من الوضع الطبي
المتدهور شمال سوريا والمعابر مع تركيا
تفتح لاستقبال الاموات والمنكوبين
مع نهايه اليوم العاشر تركيا تبدا انتشار
جثث الضحايا بلباس خاص لمنع انتشار
الاوبئه
تحقيق استقصائي لصحفينا امريكي يؤكد ان
واشنطن وراء التفجير نورتريم وموسكو تطلب
عقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
مباحثه غير مباشره بين امريكا وايران
لتبادل السجناء والافراج عن مليارات
الدولارات من الاموال الايرانيه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده مزيد دائما على
العربيه وعلى صفحاتنا على مواقع التواصل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]